the open questions there are what does
the manifestation of super intelligence
look like so like what are we going to
you talked about why do I want to merge
with AI like what what's the actual
marginal benefit here if I if we have a
super intelligent
system yeah
how will it make our life better so
let's let's that's a great question but
let's break it onto little pieces all
right on the one hand it can make our
life better in lots of simple ways you
mentioned like a care robot or something
that helps me do things or cook so I
don't know what it does right little
things like that become better smarter
cars we can have you know better agents
AIDS helping us in our work environment
and things like that to me that's like
the easy stuff the the simple stuff in
the beginning
um
um and so in the same way that computers
made our lives better in ways many many
ways I will have those kind of things
to me the really exciting thing about AI
is sort of its Transcendent Transcendent
quality in terms of humanity we're still
biological organisms we're still stuck
here on Earth it's going to be hard for
us to live anywhere else uh I don't
think you and I are going to want to
live on Mars anytime soon
um
and
um and we're flawed you know we may end
up destroying ourselves it's totally
possible uh we if not completely we
could destroy our civilizations you know
it let's face the fact we have issues
here
but we can create intelligent machines
that can help us in various ways for
example one example like announce it
sounds a little sci-fi but I believe
this if we really wanted to live on Mars
we'd have to have intelligent systems
that go there and build the habitat for
us not humans humans are never going to
do this it's just too hard
um but could we have a thousand or ten
thousand you know engineered workers up
there doing this stuff building things
terraforming marks sure maybe we can
move Mars but then if we want to if we
want to go around the universe should I
send my children around the universe so
I send some intelligent machine which is
like a child that represents me and
understands our needs here on Earth that
could travel through space
um so it sort of it in some sense
intelligence allows us to transcend our
the limitations of our biology
uh with and and don't think of it as a
negative thing it's in some sense my
children transcends my the my biology
too because they they live beyond me
yeah
um and we in part they represent me and
they also have their own knowledge and I
couldn't impart knowledge to them so
intelligent machines would be like that
too but not limited like us I mean but
the question is
um there's so many ways that
Transcendence can happen and the merger
with AI and humans is one of those ways
so you said intelligent
basically beings or systems propagating
throughout the Universe representing us
humans
they represent us humans in the sense
they represent our knowledge and our
history not us individually
right right but
I mean the question is it just a
database
with uh with a really damn good uh model
no no they were conscious conscious just
like us okay but just different they're
different uh just like my children are
different they're like me but they're
different
um these are more different
I guess maybe I've already
I kind of I take a very broad view of
our life here on on Earth I say you know
why are we living here are we just
living because we live
is it are we surviving because we can
survive are we fighting just because we
want to just keep going what's the point
of it yeah right so to me the point if I
ask myself what's the point of life is
what transcends that
ephemeral sort of biological experience
is to me this is my answer is the
acquisition of knowledge to understand
more about the universe uh and to
explore
and that's partly to learn more right
um I don't view it as a terrible thing
if the ultimate
outcome of humanity is we create systems
that are intelligent that are Offspring
but they're not like us at all
and we still we stay here and live on
earth as long as we can which won't be
forever but as long as we can
and
but that would be a great thing to do it
it's not a it's not like a negative
thing well
would uh you be okay then if uh the
human
species vanishes but our knowledge is
preserved and keeps keep being expanded
by intelligent systems
I want our knowledge to be preserved and
expanded yeah am I okay with humans die
no I don't want that to happen but if if
it does happen what if we we were
sitting here and this is we were the
last two people on Earth who are saying
Lex we blew it it's all over right yeah
wouldn't I feel better if I knew that
our knowledge was preserved and that we
had agents represent that knew about
that that were trans you know they were
that left Earth I would want that it's
better than not having that you know I
make the analogy of like you know the
Dinosaurs the poor dinosaurs they live
for you know tens of millions of years
they've raised their kids they you know
they they fought to survive they were
hungry they they did everything we do
and then they're all gone yeah like you
know and and if we didn't discover their
bones
nobody would ever know that they ever
existed right we want to be like that I
don't want to be like that